looks like Chick-fil-A will not be
opening any new restaurants in Uganda
anytime soon the longtime favorite
company of conservatives has apparently
embraced the Dei agenda
according to a heretofore unnoticed
diversity equity and inclusion segment
of Chick-fil-A's website quote one of
our core values at Chick-fil-A
Incorporated is that we are better
together when we combine our unique
backgrounds blah blah blah with a
culture of belonging we can discover new
ways to blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah the exact verbiage does not exactly
matter it's all
pretty much just gobbledygook anyway
the disconcerting thing
is not the exact wording the
disconcerting thing is that Chick-fil-A
has embraced Dei at all and now while
some conservatives are calling for a
boycott of the openly religious
generally relatively conservative
company as far as I'm concerned this
story has almost nothing to do with
Chick-fil-A
the Chick-fil-A
Dei Department
doesn't tell you a ton about the chicken
shop it tells you about the depth and
pervasiveness of a liberal ideology
throughout our entire culture
it isn't just Disney
it isn't just Target it isn't just
transheiser bush
even
Chick-fil-A
is subject to increasingly radical
liberalism and we will not merely buy
another sandwich to fix it the only way
to fix it is by resetting reorienting
our entire political order even
Chick-fil-A I'm Michael Knowles it's the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we will get to
the really important announcement out of
New York New York mayor Eric Adams
protecting obesity as a protected class
we now no longer merely defend
transgenderism we will also defend trans
slenderism we will get to that in just a
moment first though we turn
to Disney away from Chick-fil-A which
shows you that Dei wokenists it's all
just really the conclusion of liberalism
it's everywhere it's everywhere it's
even in your religious chicken sandwich
and it's especially at Disney there is a
fairly disturbing video came out of
Disneyland
out of the enchanted chamber princess
Boutique
and it is of a pretty little princess
with a mustache
it's a dude dressed up
as a princess and he's not one of the
enthusiasts he is one of the workers
there
employed by Disney take a look take a
look or a listen if you're thriving
mother's apprentices I'm here to shop
you around and make all your selections
for the day into a little girl he's got
lots of eye shadow on and just a big
bushy mustache
trying to sell extremely overpriced
dresses for little girls to those poor
poor parents who are going to have to
Shell out a ton of money
okay
what's wrong with this scene the
mustache is a problem yeah the fact that
it's an obvious dude wearing a dress
that's a problem the bigger problem
though is
who this is for
it's not even just that Disney World is
for kids and so this weird sexual stuff
has no place in front of kids
it's even more than the question of kids
or minors or what's appropriate for
certain ages it's a question of
who are these people serving what is the
point of Disney World what is the point
of any of these companies
is it about the customer or is it about
the fantasies of the employee we used to
have a saying In America which is that
the customer is always right
now the customer doesn't seem to matter
at all customer doesn't matter at all
with Bud Light and transheiser Bush
customer doesn't matter at all with
Target customer doesn't even matter at
Disney World and Disneyland
who is this for when I was a young man
I was young coming up in Show Business
and I'd sometimes take these service
industry jobs
one of which I was hired to be a fake
sommelier at a wedding the wedding was
actually for George Soros it's a story
for another time but I remember we were
all there was the Caterers and the
sommelier and all these people and the
guy who was running the event he said
hey what is this about what are we all
here for and in my mind I thought I
don't know we're here to make a quick
buck and then go back to our regular
lives but no he said no what this is all
about what this is for is service
your job here is to serve the customer
especially if you're in the service
industry
but increasingly in our economy and in
our whole culture
it's not about the customer it's not
about the people we're supposed to serve
it's somehow the other way around
little kids don't go to Disneyland so
that they can affirm some deviant man's
delusions
parents don't spend an arm and a leg to
take their kids to Disneyland so that
their kids can be exposed to a Mustachio
to strange fellow living at his fantasy
of being a pretty princess
okay if you want to take the job as a
pretty princess
you definitely have to shave the
mustache and you got to be a chick
because it's not about you and
princesses or chicks and you're not so
you've got to put your fantasies aside
especially when we're talking about a
place like Disneyland which is supposed
to indulge the fantasies of little
children who for whom it is appropriate
to have little fantasies and play act
them out sometimes for adults it's not
appropriate to do that
one of the the big cases to enshrine
transgenderism in our law was a the
Harris Funeral Home case and the Harris
Funeral Home case before The Supreme
Court
raised a question of do employees have
an obligation to follow the rules
sometimes for the benefit of their
customers there's this Funeral Home
Harris Funeral Homes and one of the
employees at the funeral home was a dude
who thought he was a chick and so one
day he decided he was going to wear
little skirts and put on lipstick and go
in and do his job and the owner of the
funeral home said hey man I I don't know
what's going on with you obviously you
got some issues but
we've got to be respectful to our
customers when people come to the
funeral home they're grieving they're in
a very vulnerable state they don't need
distractions they don't need to deal
with some weird political ideology
they're trying to grieve their dead
loved ones and so it's not about you
it's about them
and this strange fellow decided no it's
actually all about me any suit him and
he ended up winning the case now that's
enshrined in law we're not going to have
a good Society if we invert that order
are we around here to serve others in
accordance with reason and the truth or
do we just view everybody in the world
including poor little kids including
their parents who spend a lot of money
to take him to Disneyland do we just
view them merely as instruments to serve
us and our deviant desires two totally
different societies by the way when you
want to satiate your appetites and
desires the best way to do it is
obviously with good ranchers right now
head on over to goodranchers.com use
promo code Knowles this Father's Day let
your dad unleash his inner Grill Master
whether he prefers a sizzling steak or
savory grilled chicken look no further
than the gift of meat from our friends
at good ranchers good ranchers offers
Ribeyes New York strips T-Bones all
natural burgers and the most delicious
chicken you could ever want plus right
now you will get thirty three zero
dollars off with our code Knowles at
goodranchers.com good ranchers also
offers a price lock guarantee for the
next two years which is completely
insane imagine if you could have locked
in your price two years ago you would
have saved hundreds of dollars not sure
how to grill the perfect steak well
they've got tons of recipes on their
website like uh one of our great
favorites how to cook a steak better
than Gordon Ramsay whether your dad is a
steak lover a barbecue Enthusiast or
just enjoys a good old-fashioned Burger
good Rancher says the best burgers in
the business by the way unbelievable
steaks too but the burgers are making me
salivate thinking about them you gotta
order today make this Father's Day a
success go to goodranchors.com use code
knowleskin wlas for 30 off any box promo
code Knowles at goodranchors.com good
ranchers American Meat delivered you see
this kind of Madness especially in
higher education
there was a law school commencement
ceremony at CUNY
uh that featured a speaker sometimes
these commencements have student
speakers and the student speakers are
usually kind of Goody Two-Shoes types
but increasingly they can be left-wing
activists who are speaking out on behalf
of the student body and one such speech
came from Fatima Muhammad student
speaker for CUNY law school and Fatima
Muhammad made all sorts of claims she is
a pro-palestine activist she really
doesn't like Israel not a huge fan of a
certain ancient nomadic tribe of people
and so she makes her comments about that
but she's broadly against the West she's
against white people and patriarchy and
that is how her speech is being reported
pro-palestine student goes off on the
Jews or left-wing student goes off on
white supremacy and the patriarchy but
there's something even more Insidious
about this girl's law school speech see
if you can pick it up
I'm here to celebrate who and what we
are who you are like many of you I chose
CUNY school of law for its articulated
mission to be law in the service of
human needs one of very few legal
institutions created
to recognize that the law is a
manifestation of white supremacy that
continues to oppress and suppress people
in this nation and around the world we
joined this institution to be equipped
with the necessary legal skills to
protect our communities to protect the
organizers fighting endlessly day in and
out with no accolades No cameras no
votes no PhD grants working to lift the
facade of legal neutrality and confront
the systems of Oppression that wreck
violence on them
the craziest thing about this speech is
not that the pro-palestine girl hates
the Jews the craziest thing about this
speech is not that the leftist girl
hates the white people and the Man in
the patriarchy and all the rest it's
that sentence right at the top where she
says CUNY recognizes that the law
is just a facade to uphold white
supremacy the craziest thing she says in
Her speech
is about the law
because this girl graduated from law
school she was selected to be the
speaker at her law school graduation she
doesn't know what the law is she doesn't
believe in the law
the law at its most basic level is an
ordinance of reason for the common good
by the one who has care of the community
and promulgated that's the the
description of the law the definition
that Saint Thomas Aquinas gives it's a
really basic very good one
a related concept is justice justice is
a habit a virtue that inclines the will
to render to each and to all what he
deserves
again really basic definition of justice
what this girl says at her law school
graduation is oh the law Justice that's
all Bs
the law it's fake the law is totally
fake thank you for giving me my law
degree the law is totally fake it is not
an ordinance of reason it is not for the
common good it's nothing more than a
bunch of gobbledygook that we use to
enshrine the tyranny of will of of the
willfulness of one group which is the
white people or the Jews or whoever
she's going off on people that I hate
and so what we do when we go to law
school is we just get a credential that
allows us to wield this deceptive
instrument for our own tyranny of will
to to give ourselves more power and to
dominate the groups the white people and
the Jews and the men and whoever that we
hate
that's what she's saying that's the not
so subtle subtext of all of it she's
saying the law is not
objective the law is not just the law is
not real the law does not derive from
anything outside of our own desires
that's the state of higher education
that's the state of the law that's the
state of Justice in America
if our next generation of lawyers
of the people who are supposed to be
running the show in the political order
does not believe in law then we're going
to have lawlessness and I'll tell you
what
if this lady doesn't like what America
looks like with Law and Order just wait
until she sees America without Law and
Order
because yes the the positive law the
civil law is sometimes an imperfect
reflection of the natural law and the
background principles of justice that
that exist even outside of our own
personal experience and desire yeah
that's true yes it's true that the
system of justice is imperfect and
sometimes innocent people go to jail and
sometimes guilty people get off the hook
and yeah that's all true
but if you if you think a law-abiding
America is bad just wait until you see a
Lawless America this is how I feel about
attacks on Christian nationalism
Christian religious right
people say I hate the religious right of
men you think the religious right is bad
just wait until you see that you're
religious right or the irreligious left
though I suppose that's a redundant
phrase
oh you think Christian nationalism is
bad just wait until you see unchristian
nationalism
that because that's going to be a lot
worse
a society where even the people who
graduate with the law degrees don't
think there's anything objective here so
then
where does that leave us well that
leaves us of course with a lot of Latino
White supremacists
according to the New Yorker we are now
seeing the rise of Latino
white supremacy
at a time of rising racial violence
Latinos are potential perpetrators and
potential victims this author goes on
about all the terrible white
supremacists that allegedly are running
rampant in America and then focuses in
on some Latino people who are committing
all sorts of crimes and they try to pin
it on white supremacy they'll say for
one of these guys Garcia Garcia
continued to see himself as Latino which
he never equated with whiteness and at
moments he manifested pride in his
non-white Latino
identity but nevertheless he's a white
supremacist
of course
because as I've mentioned before on the
show
white just means bad white is just a
synonym for bad
so Badness
has to in some way be the fault of white
people and whiteness and when Badness is
being committed by black people it's
somehow got to be the fault of white
people
because I don't know because the white
people failed to pay enough taxes to put
the black
kid in a good school and so that's why
he went out and committed crimes
it's not because the white people
undermined the Black Culture in such a
way that the black kid grew up in a
broken home
when a Latino goes out and commits a
crime it has to be the purp the fault of
a white person because the Latino in his
mind he viewed himself as a white person
and even I guess in this case of this
guy Garcia he didn't actually view
himself as a white person it was pretty
explicit about how he didn't think of
himself as a white person but
nevertheless it the white people the
whiteness is so infected his mind that
he's got it was trust me guys it was
white supremacy
it just has to be
because
that's the starting point
that's the premise so it just has to be
that has to be the place where you end
up so why why do these people hate white
people so much why does Fatima Muhammad
giving the speech at CUNY hate white
people so much why does the New Yorker
hate white people so much why do
so many of the prominent powerful
institutions in the media in education
in politics in everywhere why do they
hate white people because
white people are a symbol of authority
and tradition
until very recently America was an
overwhelmingly white country and always
had been until very recently the West
broadly was overwhelmingly white and so
white people we live in an incarnate
world in time and space where flesh
really matters white people just become
the symbol of authority and the symbol
of tradition
and leftism
opposes those things
whatever you want to say about the
French Revolution you can't say that it
was an anti-white Revolution right
whatever you want to say about the early
liberal movements the early
um the early revolutions that unseated
so much of our settled order
they weren't about
overthrowing white people they were
about overthrowing Authority they were
about overthrowing tradition so why do
white people get such a bad rap these
days why do white people get blamed for
things and they have nothing to do with
because the the liberal Revolution seeks
to overthrow Authority and tradition and
that's the same Revolution that we've
seen going back all the way to the
Garden of Eden which is ye shall be as
gods don't do what you're told to do
don't follow the rules don't follow the
law the law is nothing but what you want
the law to be oh the law forget about
the law having any objective reasonable
intelligible aspect no it's just
whatever you want to be Humpty Dumpty on
the wall talking to Alice in Wonderland
he says words they don't mean anything
words mean whatever I say they are to
mean because the question is which is to
be Master that's what it's all about
you're now seeing it manifest in this
way there's anti-patriarchy anti-white
blah blah blah
where does this come from I know that
there are a lot of people who want to
try to
cut the fringiest parts of the left away
from the rest of it so sometimes you'll
hear people say we want to cut the T off
of LGBT
with LGB is fine but the T that's the
bad one because that that one's crazy
failing to recognize that the t is a
logical consequence of the LGB the LGB
says that men and women are basically
the same and interchangeable
that's how you can have marriage which
existed as a an institution the basic
fundamental political institution for
all of human history that's how you can
have that radically redefined such that
a man and a woman in this special Union
can now also be a man and a man and a
woman and a woman well the only way
that's possible is if men and women are
interchangeable but if men and women are
interchangeable
then it's not a very far leap to get to
transgenderism which says a man and a
woman are interchangeable which says
that a man can become a woman there are
a lot of people who want to chop the
wokeness off of liberalism or even off
of leftism they use all these different
ISM words they say no I'm a true liberal
I'm a classical liberal I'm not a
progressive liberal those these modern
vocas they're illiberal liberals but I'm
a Liberal Liberal Liberal Liberal
Liberal no it's just
this is the natural consequence of
liberalism
which
reorients Society away from God away
from good away from truth away from
beauty toward the self
and liberalism says well I am myself I
can do basically whatever I want I don't
need to follow a particular moral order
I'm not worn primarily with obligation
I'm born primarily with rights and
entitlement and so I'm going to pursue
whatever I want liberalism which says
well we can never really know the truth
all that all that well and so we've got
to remain skeptical skeptical of
basically everything and you can't
impose your views on me man
liberalism which says the settled order
is bad Prejudice is bad tradition is bad
and we're going to overthrow that
that's always been what liberalism is I
know there are some people on the right
who get confounded when they have to
give a definition of wokeness or leftism
or radicalism or whatever it's just the
logical conclusion
of all of this stuff
so if if we're going to move past it you
can't just try to excise the most
radical crazy part okay well we're gonna
just get rid of tranzing the
five-year-olds but transiting the 19
year olds that's okay and transgenderism
broadly is okay and LGBT ism is okay and
pride is okay and feminism is okay and
this isn't and that is nah guys
you've got to offer people a choice
rather than merely an echo otherwise if
you just try to rewind the clock 18
months you just try to rewind the clock
18 years
doesn't matter you say we're in a reset
Society in 2003 that was the peak of
society
if you've got all the same ideas there
propelling people along then those ideas
are going to have consequences and
you're going to end up in the same crazy
spot
so we've got to talk to each other about
this when you want to talk to each other
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles
we're all trying to improve the country
here aren't we and therefore we've got
to be a little bit Discerning about the
partners that we choose to work with and
one company I'm very very proud to stand
behind and a company that's very proud
to stand behind us and our country is
pure talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs our desires for this country
that is why Pure Talk is the official
cell phone wireless partner of the daily
wire but that's not the only reason Pure
Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the United
States they've got a top tier service at
a fraction of the cost of those other
woke companies you know the ones I'm
talking about ATT Verizon T-Mobile those
companies that don't care about you or
your values in fact you can get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote with how you spend your
money so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Knowles you will get
rate coverage and save while you're
doing it go to puretalk.com Knowles save
an additional fifty five zero percent
off your first month because they
actually care about you go to
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans buy Americans you know
I hate to Pat myself on the back don't
want to toot my own horn but I'll tell
you Michael and is quickly becoming one
of our most popular shows Michael and
it's just where I and somebody else sit
down and have a long conversation it's
unscripted I basically prepare nothing I
want to just find interesting people you
probably haven't heard of and figure out
what makes them tick figure out what's
going on in their lives how they've
ended up where they are you've heard
some experiences from a psychonaut
a guy who went down a lot of weird
psychedelic rabbit Trails I spoke with
an exorcist father Dan rehill that that
interview two hour long interview it has
over three million views at this point
you will hear firsthand stories that
will blow your mind in the latest
episode I sat down with Joshua Broome
who went from making well over a million
dollars in the porn industry he even won
male porn star of the year to being
minutes away from taking his own life
what he told me about the horrors of the
porn industry and his radical
transformation will
shock and I think Delight you check out
this teaser you know I did a thousand
films over about a six year period you
had to have a current
um like full panel like STD and AIDS
test you would look is the test clear
great and that's what I would know about
the girl until I walked into the room
and had sex with him
[Music]
this episode and the rest of the series
are available now in the Michael Knowles
Show YouTube channel so go check them
out after the show
speaking of going after those darn white
people Jane Fonda says we need to
imprison white men
Jane Fonda of Hanoi Jane Fame she's the
lady who allowed the
Vietnamese Communists to sit her down on
an anti-aircraft gun and make like she
was shooting down American
flyers and attacking American troops she
later apologized for that but then she
remained a huge anti-American lib so the
content of that apology is somewhat
dubious Jane Fonda just said quote
it's good for us all to realize there
would be no climate crisis if there was
no racism
there would be no climate crisis if
there was no patriarchy
a mindset that sees everything in a
hierarchical way white men are the
things that matter and then everything
else is at the bottom that's the problem
this mindset that sees things in a
hierarchical way by the way white men
are the absolute worst I love She's
attacking this hierarchical white male
way of thinking and how does she do it
she arranges it in a hierarchy of evil
people at the very top of the hierarchy
of evilness at the very bottom of the
hierarchy of goodness she puts the white
men okay she says that poor people of
color
as well as people in the southern
hemisphere will be hit hardest by global
warming she says it's a tragedy that we
have to absolutely stop we have to
arrest and jail those men they're all
men
okay all those white men we've got to
throw them in jail because they're
pushing global warming
maybe worth pointing out to Hanoi Jane
that as far as Nations go
the biggest contributor to global
warming such as it is is a China
uh China which famously does not have a
lot of white men running it
but regardless yeah sure America we're a
big industrial country we're the leader
of the Free World and so there are still
a great good number of white men in
America and okay
that's the problem
climate crisis
would not exist if not for patriarchy
the climate crisis would not exist for
racism the climate crisis is the fault
of white men of course it is it has to
be
and climate change catastrophic climate
change we're just nine years away from
the end of the world as they've been
telling us for 50 years uh that also
requires white men to be the fault of it
because
white people just equals bad
climate change equals
secular apocalypse
and so yes evil
will bring about the end of the world
and in the Christian understanding of
the Apocalypse things get really really
really bad as Sin and death and evil
pervade all the world and the prince of
this world leads to all sorts of
terrible things you know the devil the
father of Lies but then there's a happy
ending there is a happy ending here
because Christ wins the war and comes
down and you have the final judgment in
the secular version of this now we just
all turn to worm food evil in the
secular version in the leftist version
evil just wins
and this shapes the way that we view the
world
this is education Hanoi Jane's comments
here
Fatima Muhammad's comments at CUNY law
school the dude in the dress at
Disneyland all of this stuff
the Latino white supremacy this
constitutes education a lot more than
the Reading Writing and arithmetic that
you'll learn in fifth grade
education is about how we're brought up
it's about how we view the world I was
thinking about this the other day
because I have friends and relatives who
are a bit neurotic and they worry a lot
about death
but they never think about death they
don't really take death seriously but
they worry about dying
and I was thinking about myself and it's
easy for me to say I'm relatively
healthy guy and a sunshine in my life
but I think about death all the time
but I almost never worry about death
how is that well I think about death all
the time because I'm Christian and so I
think about okay if I committed a sin am
I in a state of grace do I need to go to
confession what am I going to have a
good death I mean this was something
that
Christians for the vast majority of our
civilization's history they would think
about this sort of thing am I prepared
to meet my maker because death comes
like a thief in the night you never know
if you're going to go okay so you think
about death a lot but then if you
prepare for death you're not worried
about death I think okay I don't think I
turned to worm food I hope I don't go to
hell I think I'm preparing myself for
for the end of the story
okay good whereas if you ignore death if
you try to put it out of your mind
you're still going to have that nagging
sense of your mortality that's part of
the human condition and so paradoxically
you're going to be much much more
worried about it the more you try to put
it out of the Mind the more you're going
to be worried about it then it that all
of that got me thinking
this is our real education this is the
real kind of education that guides our
society it's not just the Reading
Writing and arithmetic it's not just the
facts about which wars were won by which
generals the real basis of our education
is
who do we think we are where do we think
we're going what do we think we're made
for what do we think good is what do we
think we're all doing here together
that's the really subtle stuff of our
education that's going to make or break
a civilization
where are we what are we for and for
Jane Fonda her understanding of evil and
good and progress and politics and all
of that it is informed by things that
are false and ugly and and wicked
and that's going to drive a civilization
crazy that the education crisis in
America is so much deeper the education
crisis goes to the goes to the heart of
religion being pushed out of the Public
Square goes to the heart of or a whole
cast of people being called evil and the
whole cast of people that
disproportionately have guided our
nation's history being called evil so we
view our nation as evil so we just have
fallen into a national malaise you can't
separate these sorts of issues and what
are we doing to stop it we're passing
legal protections for fat people that's
what we're doing Eric Adams in New York
liberal mayor of New York even though
he's relatively better than the last
Bolshevik that we had in the mayor's
office in New York Bill de Blasio
Eric Adams
doubling down on identity politics
to sign a weight discrimination bill
into law
I think it is uh you know everyone knows
that uh I'm a person that believes in
health uh so when you talk about not
discriminating against someone because
of their body type is not fighting
against obesity it's just being fair and
so I think this is this is the right
thing to do we're going to continue to
talk about uh our Progressive Health
agenda and science has shown that body
type is not a connection to if you're
healthy or unhealthy and I think that's
a misnomer that we are we are really
dispelling
foreign
I love the weak Applause they're that
one guy the one staffer in the back of
the room again we've realized that the
science has shown us that if you're a
big gigantic Fatso that has nothing to
do with your health that's totally
divorced from you you can be just the
biggest fattest
most out of shape guy in the whole world
and you could be healthier than an
Olympic runner
yeah yeah good is that good is that
we all know that isn't true
we all yes it's true that they're going
to be skinny people who have health
problems yes it can be true that there
can be huskier people who are relatively
in good health but if you're like a big
fatso that's a problem and it's a
problem that you should work on I'm not
saying you're a bad person not saying
that you should be ostracized from
society not saying that all hope is lost
quite the opposite I'm saying you ought
to be encouraged to live in a way that
is healthier because you're more likely
to flourish you're more likely to live
longer you're more likely to live in a
more pleasant way for a longer period of
time and you're more likely to feel good
about yourself and you're more likely to
excel in other areas as well because
we're integrated human beings we all
know that what that guy said isn't true
almost certainly including Eric Adams
Eric Adams doesn't believe that if
you're 400 pounds you're the Pinnacle of
Health okay
but we just lie because we're so used to
lying now because we lie and we tell men
who pretend to be women we tell the
Mustachio guy and the pretty princess
outfit we say oh yeah no you really are
a woman yeah oh just because you have a
mustache and certain other appendages
that doesn't mean you're a man it does
we all know that it does oh no man what
are you talking about
just because criminals are marauding all
over the streets and stealing our stuff
and killing people that doesn't mean
we're unsafe just because we have an
open border and we've got millions of
people pouring across it every year that
doesn't mean we're failing as a nation
that doesn't mean that we have an
unstable political order no what are you
talking about just because just because
we've got record high inflation and
people can't afford their basic
necessities that doesn't mean the
economy is Magic no it does man it does
just admit reality what you're seeing
here is attention that Patrick Dineen
actually talks about in his excellent
new book which I'll I'll be working on a
review for soon uh but he makes the
point that our society is really torn
between two conflicting impulses that
every parent faces and the conflicting
impulses are for
acceptance
and Improvement
if your kid comes to your kids going
through some sort of problem let's say I
don't know
your kid
gets a stupid looking tattoo
let's say you can't get a bunch of
stupid looking tattoos and is not
treating their body well on the one hand
you want to encourage your kid to stop
making poor decisions to improve your
kids life but on the other hand you
don't want your kid to feel like you've
rejected him and you don't want him
anymore and he can't turn to you so you
also want to accept your kid and this is
true with so many issues it's true every
parent's gonna have to deal with this at
some point raising kids and it's true
for our society as well
you don't want to seem like you
especially see this for for young people
who are less and less young with each
passing year and they haven't gotten
married and they haven't settled down
and they haven't had kids and they
haven't done the basic things that are
conducive to a flourishing Society
you don't want to just reject those
people and say oh yeah now you're washed
up sorry especially for women oh yeah
women you're you're single you're you're
single and you're a little bit older
yeah you're a joke we don't want you
anymore no not at all you're not saying
you don't want them in society you're
not saying you can't live a flourishing
life you're not saying that the
difficulties that they're living with
are their fault entirely but you also
want to encourage younger people to
try to break out of the the liberal
trans and to maybe say no I don't need
to go get 50 000 different academic
degrees to the cost of half a million
dollars and I don't need to totally
neglect my personal life and I don't
need to put off having children I don't
need to put off getting married so you
want to encourage the society while also
accepting the society as it is in all of
its diversity and we've just fallen way
too far
on the latter category such that we're
pretending people with mustaches can be
princesses and that 400 pound people
can be just as healthy as fit people not
so now speaking of encouragement our
first lady
I'm sorry not our first lady our vice
president
our vice president has just come out to
encourage the U.S military academy at
West Point and she has done so with
soaring periclean rhetoric
as I look out at you
I know that you will build on that
leadership because of course your
generation grew up online
technology that might be intimidating or
unfamiliar to other Generations
to you is exciting and intuitive
you see what can be unburdened by what
has been
and you have the agility and the ability
to bring that potential to life
great examples of political rhetoric
uh we have nothing to fear but fear
itself
Mr Gorbachev tear down this wall
[Music]
you know what you can be unburdened by
what has been
be and Ben and B and Ben this is a line
that Kamala Harris has used once or
twice before
I can imagine what can be and be
unburdened by what has been you know
what can be unburdened by what has been
what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been what we can
see what we believe can be unburdened by
what has been what can be unburdened by
what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been who we can
be
unburdened by who we have been what can
be unburdened by what has been where we
can be unburdened by where we have been
and unburdened by where we are right now
what can be
unburdened by what has been one thing I
love about Kamala Harris is she is her
own sign language interpreter so you
don't need the little lady in the corner
of the screen she uses this line a lot
there is a compilation that the RNC put
out that it goes on for three and a half
minutes of what can be what has been and
it sounds like a stupid meaningless line
it sounds like the sort of line that a
12 year old would write in his first
essay for class where he doesn't realize
that essays require facts and arguments
that are not just a meaningless string
of words together but there actually is
a lot of meaning in that phrase of
Kamala Harris she might not even know it
but there is a lot of meaning it really
sums up the liberal project which we'll
get to in a second first I want to help
restore balance to your body and some
balance to nature which is why you got
to check out balance of nature right now
go to balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle is
not always easy especially when you are
on the go you need simple manageable
routines to make sure you are getting
the proper nutrition every single day
that's why I'm a huge fan of balance of
nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to ensure that
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every day their capsules are
packed with 100 whole food that you can
take at any time balance of nature uses
a cold vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for us to try and these absolute
jackals around here just gobbled them up
we had to claw over each other to try to
get them from these hyenas so make sure
that you get your own balance of nature
right now go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knolls Canada wlas for 35 off
your first order as a preferred customer
that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
kwles for 35 percent off your first
preferred order with Father's Day coming
up I've been thinking about how grateful
I am that my dad never became a chick
for all of my father's many
accomplishments I think the greatest
accomplishment might be that he remained
a dude and he is one of two people who
helped to give me my life without him I
wouldn't be here well that might be a
strange thing to say we live in strange
times and so we shouldn't take the
simplest gifts for granted show your
appreciation and gratitude for your dad
making the Bold choice to remain the
gender he was assigned at Birth with a
gift from Jeremy's razors right now they
have a 30 off sale on select bundles and
razor starter kits they're 100 woke free
they're unashamed to celebrate
masculinity so this Father's Day do not
just give him any gift give him Jeremy's
razors the gift that says thank you Dad
for being and staying a man thank you
Dad for man's missioning go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today take 30 off
our razors and not 100 off your genitals
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Old School hey old school just back in
one of the great commenters for years on
this show who says
calling yourself non-binary
categorizes everyone as binary
or non-binary
this creates a binary system which makes
you binary again
that's so true that's actually a really
good point old school not only because
it owns the libs but because it reminds
us that ultimately
all of our choices are binary
because all of our choices are going to
come down to the transcendentals
we're either going to do good or evil
we're either going to pursue truth or
falsehood we're either going to move
toward beauty or toward ugliness
most things ultimately are binary
there's all sorts of Shades of Gray in
this complex world man but ultimately
those things are in fact binary so true
now how do we think about it well we
think about it in a way that allows us
to see what we can be unburdened by what
has been
like Kamala Harris encourages us to do
I hope not
I want to be burdened by what has been
I am pro-burden I don't want to be
overly burdened I don't want to be born
down and crushed by burdens that are
destructive to me
but we need some kind of Burden I mean
even Christ in the gospels our Lord
tells us that you don't you don't want
to have the shackles of sin on you'll be
a slave to sin but you should put
his burden on you because his yoke is
easy and his burden is light it says
take up your cross and bear it
we we will have some kinds of burdens
and so what are we in political Society
going to be burdened with what Kamala
Harris uses a burden is tradition is
Authority is reality what has been and
what she's arguing for is the same thing
John F Kennedy and his brother Robert
Kennedy argued for and a lot of other
liberals have argued for since the 60s
which is that quote some people see
things that are and say why I dream
things that never were and say why not
which is a quote that the author George
Bernard Shaw put into the mouth of the
serpent tempting Eve in the Garden of
Eden this is the the same Temptation
that the serpent gives us in the Genesis
account
which is ye shall be as gods
you surely shall not die no no you'll
have the knowledge of Good and Evil and
you you shall be as gods
don't worry about what has been that's
all forget about that
just let's let's just move forward
through our imagination it's just
that same old satanic line going back to
the Garden of Eden and Kamal Harris
almost certainly doesn't know it because
she's not the most conscious or
reflective politician in the world
but and in fact that's probably why a
lot of Libs I've noticed who are not
really conscious about politics they
just say nonsense they just repeat all
sorts of platitudes they'll say look
Everything's Relative
you know look Everything's Relative
relative hey you do you
you do you it is what it is you do you
Everything's Relative these kinds of
sayings that seem meaningless that
people just recite thoughtlessly they
all boil down to really dark ideas
actually they all they all frankly boil
down to the Aleister Crowley Satanist
first commandment which is do what thou
Wilt shall be the entirety of the law
right it just says just do whatever you
want ignore the moral order don't pursue
goodness just do whatever you want it's
fine there's no meaning it's all
relative there's no truth there's no
judgment there's no nothing
and and that's what Kamala Harris as the
as the symbol
of your kind of liberal wine aunt in
America
she is repeating that too and she's
repeating that from one of the highest
podiums in the United States now
speaking of those podia in the U.S and
ladies babbling from it Corrine
Jean-Pierre
is bringing us back to some really
important issues
uh namely you know that third world war
that broke out over the conflict in
Ukraine that we haven't been talking
about very much well seek Miller one of
the great journalists in the White House
Press pool Zeke Miller
uh just asked kjp
about
these kinds of attacks
so look I'm going to be very clear we're
gathering information I'm not going to
get into hypotheticals uh from here we
do not support the use of uh us-made
equipment being used uh for attacks
inside of Russia we've been very clear
about that and we'll continue to do that
and we have been clear not just publicly
but privately clearly with the
ukrainians but not going to get into
hypotheticals we're going to look into
gather information to see exactly what
happened so we can get some clarity but
as I said we've been very clear so Zeke
is asking about these increasing
Ukrainian attacks on Russia potential
drone attack on the Kremlin potential
attacks on Russian soil and don't forget
we've funded the Ukraine war we funded
the Ukraine side so these attacks are
going to be carried out
most likely with our Weaponry with our
material so does that mean that now the
United States a nuclear superpower is
engaging in a hot war with a nuclear
reformer superpower Russia
that doesn't seem like a great idea and
so the White House is trying to run away
from this
the White House is trying to say no we
don't support that we don't support
ukrainians using American
military equipment against the Russians
wait what and why do we give them the
military equipment well no we we support
them using the American military
equipment against the Russians on
Ukrainian soil but not on Russian soil
um do you think that's how War Works do
you think you can give a nation all
sorts of equipment and say okay but here
are the very special rules you've got to
use
especially a country in this corrupt
part of the world in Eastern Europe
Ukraine not exactly the most transparent
well-run country ever in a fight for its
life against Russia you think you really
think that that's what's going to happen
it's almost as though War has unintended
consequences and it's almost as though
the people leading us are absolutely
feckless and sleepwalking us into World
War III the prime minister of Georgia
not the state but the country prime
minister of Georgia was just asked for
his take on the hostilities in Ukraine
and he you can tell he's a little bit
uncomfortable saying this he says hey
maybe NATO Bears a little bit of the
blame here
why do you think Russia launched that
invasion of Ukraine in 2022 I think
everybody everybody knows the reason I'm
not sure I do what do you think it is I
think you know it well and the audience
knows it one of the main reasons were
NATO right
NATO enlargement right
and many other reasons you think that
NATO enlargement provoked the the war
well I I don't want to speculate okay
and I don't want to quote the statements
of the Russian government
but one of the reasons was
uh Ukraine's
uh will and determination to become
member of NATO
uh and uh
so therefore
we see the consequence
okay now what a lot of people in the
west especially in the liberal
establishment are going to say is this
prime minister of Georgia he's just
repeating Russian propaganda he's trying
to blame Putin's invasion of Ukraine on
NATO
well it's not just the prime minister of
Georgia who clearly doesn't he doesn't
want to irritate NATO too much here but
he's he's giving his view on what's
going on and he's obviously in Eastern
European who's got a particular view of
this thing but
it's not just him who's saying this I
was warning about this at the outbreak
of the hostilities you know I hate to
say I told you so but I said hey buffer
states have played an important role in
history and as NATO has expanded
Eastward
this has provoked Russia and it wasn't
just me saying this was yorum hazoni the
Israeli philosophers were saying this
but it wasn't even just me and yorum who
were kind of modern day conservatives
it was Henry Kissinger it was Sam Nunn
it was Daniel Patrick Moynihan it was
George Kennan the author of The Long
Telegram one of the architects of
American Cold War policy this was going
back all the way to the 90s
there were wise Statesmen who said hey
NATO should stop aggressively expanding
Eastward that's going to needlessly
provoke Russia and unless NATO is going
to gobble up the whole world in wars of
conquest and there are and there have
been some aggressive actions by NATO
it's not not been a purely defensive
Alliance which I'm sure Russia is seeing
as well
if NATO is going to keep expanding
Eastward that is going to create
precarious situation it's going to
provoke a war
and then what happens Russia which
already wanted to enlarge itself again
to reclaim some of the territory of the
Soviet Union which Vladimir Putin says
the collapse of the Soviet Union was the
greatest cataclysmic event of the 20th
century so you know you've got that
desire there all of a sudden things
start to spin out of control
all of it was predictable
there were plenty of conservatives
warning people of this and you look at
our feckless leadership you are reminded
this is the point I made yesterday if we
wanted to have a stable political order
a good political order we've got to
replace the current Elite we've got to
replace the people Personnel or policy
and these people don't know the
difference between a man and a woman
these people claim that if you're 400
pounds you're you're the Pinnacle of
Health these people don't know that a
baby is a baby these people blame white
men for Latino criminals these people do
not have a strong grip on reality and
these are the people on whom we depend
to avert World War III
not a great situation to be in now today
is woke Wednesday
the producers of this show have assured
me they've got a very important video
they want me to watch react to just
Channel all of my cultural and
ideological knowledge into analysis of
this video and I want to talk to you the
creme de La Creme the earner circle of
this show
you can do that at dailywear.com Knowles
use code Knowles at check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]